- So, you met one of your
idols recently, right?
Working?-
- Yes.
- So wait, how was it and who was it?
Tell everybody.
- So, Mel C, Sporty Spice.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Deon] What?
- Oh, an icon-
- Still looks fantastic-
- Amazing.
- Oh my God.
- She is the hardest working
member of the Spice Girls.
So, you know, like, and it still shows,
it was just surreal having
this person I looked up to
and being on the same show as her,
and honestly, I loved sharing
this experience with her
because it's really, you've
done reality TV shows
like, it's nerve wracking.
You don't know what's gonna happen
at the end of every episode,
and so, what I loved about
having her by my side
was always talking about
like the nervousness
and the anxiety that we might
feel before we performed,
and I was like, if a Spice Girl,
who sold out stadiums is getting nervous
like, it's okay that
I'm nervous, you know?
- But everyone I talk to that
does Dancing with the Stars,
they always say, it's just
like the hardest thing ever,
Everyone,-
- It is grueling.
- It doesn't matter if it's
like an Olympian or a housewife.
It doesn't matter who
it is, they're all like,
it's the hardest thing
ever, schedule wise.
- [Cody] It is crazy, it's like,
- Why do you sign up to do it?
Like that's my, like as
soon as someone says that,
I'm like, never, I'm like, nope.
- I hid that I liked their song.
- [Cody] Yeah?
- Yeah, I hid that I liked their song.
- Oh, it was like a guilty pleasure?
- [Deon] When it first came out.
- Oh yeah,
What do you mean,-
- Won't let nobody know-
If you wanna be my lover?
- That I loved it.
- But you were turning it up,
You were turning-
- Yeah, like, my boys-
The volume in the car.
- Would get in the car
- And I'll be like, aiight y'all,
talk to y'all later.
♪ I'll tell you what I want ♪
♪ What I really, really want ♪
(audience clapping)
- Oh my God, I love it,
it reached everyone.
- Everybody
- It reached everyone.